he is visiting us from New York super
excited to have him he has over 100
Facebook friends everybody so huge deal
everyone please welcome Ponce yeah Thank
You merits pretty cool
I date a lot of weird and Jose is one
one who was really into yoga and choke
since I was like do you enjoy me
breathing or not I am dating I'm single
I get to meet my soul mate
I'd be anything maybe it's her fault she
please get out vacation women are
beautiful and everyone think they should
matter beautiful which I understand but
how do you think even women are created
[Laughter]
a part of the sexy process stop trying
to scare me please
yes thank me our children will be very
beautiful well there will be great
engineers and supportive
I love dating you know I was out of date
of this apparel and shoes like did you
know that because I could make a baby my
vagina is technically a 3d picture like
not even accurate your womb is the 30
adventure your vagina is the trip
something better way to get there deeper
eternally missing one thing with lots of
errors takes nine months to print and
the most time it's printing is
complaining
needless to say I did not see me trace
at night the train last night yeah I was
hanging out with a homophobic friend of
mine who's checking dating advice like
dude I'm gonna talk to women maybe your
baby woman should learn oh listen honey
the Federal Reserve Party delegated he
was I'm saying dude you can't we're so
lucky we're not gay can you imagine most
of the gender we were trying to do was
it even attracted to us back even
imagine
they missed by all the time those people
their experience like we were separate
tripping I love the gays you know I
don't understand homophobia this one
person was like it's Adam and Eve not
Adam and Steve but I don't believe we're
not even a good couple biblically first
of all they disobeyed God and a fruit
they weren't supposed to eat which is
kind of gay and then there was Cain and
Abel and Cain murdered Abel or they get
parenting advice from people raised
murderer they're only three of the
people on earth because the quarter of
the world's population the whole world
together half the genetic diversity
super-crazy races I'm not a racist
of course I hate people too I just get
to know them first we need people for
their skin I need people for their souls
so much deeper I am Asian or the
military Chinese I'm from a province in
china called south korea
love being Asian yeah because we're so
perfect that every way people make fun
of us this week dogs which I understand
is very shocking because in America dogs
are treated like family members but in
Asia we treat our family members
activities this is a little tradition we
have in Asia where instead of buying an
animal we love a grandma
unless she's a baby girl it's whole life
not just once love being Asian hey miss
Michael people to themselves find an
affordable car dominate certain
industries it's gonna be hard to avoid
us you know me agent I like the General
Tso's chicken because it's not really a
ship fish
my agent was like dude General Tso's
chicken isn't that a shitty Americanized
version of something authentically Asian
like yeah but somebody's over three of
the different races I was on a plane
once and I saw dude reading a book in
Arabic which is kind of freaky
but then I saw pull the corner of the
page and put the book away I was like oh
thank god he's got future plans
beginning middle out of bed so not a
racist
I am also a big fan of the Black Panther
movie I thought that was great movie
because it gave black children a hero
they could finally look up to and not
just someone like Martin Luther King jr.
malcolm bannister
Harriet something very rare the pardon
sir Oprah Maya Angelou - Jordan - jay-z
a lot of people cofee and I must admit
that one
Fredrik that was there's a bunch now
they have a papers in that there's like
a cat what are we gonna have a movie huh
the yellow Panther movie Jack Black Jack
Black Panther CGI race Wars those are
fun I love whites oh I think I think
white pride is a good thing you know but
a lot of people doing it correctly
they're always like the Nazis or the
Confederate flag that never into
building a castle or yotally this is no
way pride that's just racism you know to
be white to be races I can eat the Jews
- okay I love rednecks because rednecks
could survive in any wilderness
situation that you put them in except a
situation where everyone has equal
rights
if you live in a swamp with an alligator
I can't live in a cul-de-sac with a
minority figure it out
we tried smiling I love politics I'm a
big proponent of universal basic income
I think if everyone got $1,000 every
month you guys would be a lot more
bearable to be around I don't understand
these CEOs at middle managers who are
like how am I supposed to motivate my
employees if I can't burn them with
homelessness I mean if I want people to
work my company have to have a company
people want to work for it Healthcare
don't work for us I love capitalism I
think capitalism is great but don't make
everyone play a stupid game I like
fortnight I don't make your grandma play
and take away our house if she loses I
am NOT a communist to support any
policies that are Republicans would
consider it communism which is whenever
two or more people gather to do
something nice I like how many kids will
be like communism never works as if they
can expect billions of dollars and kill
millions of people to make sure we don't
work
remember Vietnam is they're pretty
anxious about it now working communism
never works because whenever people
control the means of production the
democratically elected leaders in
seriously tender and small rubber would
always find automatic weapons
stupid communist I don't understand
because people who hate immigrants
they're like you know who's taking all
my money it's people with less money
than me what about the people with the
money I live in a car so fully communist
I live in a car the reason I live in a
car is so that I could pursue company
full-time so if you didn't think I was
funny I'm sorry I'm trying really hard I
know someone's in the back yeah that was
funny but not living your car funny
buddy it makes the hard to date living
in a car usually when a date goes well
what happens is when you go for a drive
like they work up the courage to tell
her we ride 45 minutes ago
[Laughter]
[Applause]